Kim geliyor mu Teşekkür ederim Alkışlar
için biraz motivasyon oldu bu kırmızı
çıkmıyoruz değil mi
Öncelikle
tanımayanlar için kısaca bir kendimi
tanıtayım adım Mustafa
değer musluk usulü daha çok isim
tanınıyor
[Müzik]
10 yıldır Daha doğrusu bu yazla birlikte
10 sene bir devireceğim Türkiye'de
daha önce Türkiye'yi bisikletle Ee yani
Türkiye'nin Birçok yerini gezdiğim için
bu sahnede şu an bulunmakta yani
bulunuyorum Bundan dolayı işte oradaki
anılarımdır yaşadıklarım Anadolu
insanıyla Ee oturup kalkıştıklarımızı
paylaşacağım Bu arada ben öğrenciyim
her yerde de gururla söylerim
[Müzik]
uluslararası imam hatipler
duymuşsunuzdur orada FSM uluslararası
öğrencilerin ilk kurbanlarıyız
bizim bizim üstümüzde deney yaptılar bu
işi olur dediler ondan sonra arkasından
tekrar tekrar öğrenciler gelmiş Burada
Umut hoca var bizim tarih hocamız
Kendisi bu buluşmanın vesilesi oldu Çok
teşekkür ediyorum
şimdi
söylüyor ya şöyle yapalım son böyle
konuşmanın sonunda hep ayakta
alkışlarsınız
Öncelikle Bu gezinin adı Afrika'dan
selamdır bu geziyi yapmamın amacı her
yerde de anlatırım Biz 100 yıl önce
bir Türk milleti ya da bir mısırlıyla
bir Faslı tanışıyorduk Yani bir yüz yıl
önce çok uzak değil
Ama bu yüzyıl içerisinde ne olduysa o
kadar Yabancı olduk ki birbirimize
Türkiye'yi Biz gelmeden her yerde
anlatırım Biz sizi Arap zannediyorduk
meğerse Siz de biz Arap zannediyor
musunuz
öyle bir Komik bir durum nasıl oluştu bu
yüzyıl içerisinde diye böyle kara kara
düşünüyor herkes biz ilki geldiğimizde
sokaklarda geçiyoruz
mesela bakarcı araba bak he Arap falan
diye sesleniyor Biz de herhalde yani iyi
hissettiğinden Hani buradaki Mesela
çorumlunun sana işte Çorumluyum de falan
demesine benzer bir şekilde hani kendi
çektiğimden dolayı herhalde araba bak ya
bana Arap diyor diye İçimizden
geçiriyoruz
gel zaman git zaman bu Arapça Arap diye
çağırılma olayı artık bir canımızı sıktı
He şöyle olay şöyle gelişiyor artık
Arap kelimesini duymak istemiyorum yani
ve şunu fark ediyoruz şimdi o değil Ben
Arap değilim Bana kim bu Arap dediği
Türklerin Arap olduğunu kim söyledi Ya
da türküleri benim Arap olduğumu kim
söyledi Yani bu Ee birbirimizi bu Bir de
Arap kelimesini biliyorsunuz Normalde
Arap kelimesini dinimizin duasında ondan
sonra
Kur'an'da da geçtiği üzere Arap böyle
çok
kötülen Bedevi anlamı ayrı Ama
Kur'an'ın Arapçadan indirilmesi kurtlar
bizim
istila haklarımız Yani terimlerimiz
önemli terimler Ama bunun birbirimizde
öyle bir soğuttular ki ve Birbir
imiz tanımıyoruz Türk mü
bitti
beyazsa ve Arap şey beyaz Müslüman gibi
duruyorsa Araptır diye Öğrettiler bize
ya da beyaz
ve burada şunu fark ettim
Bazı yabancı öğrenciler burada yıllar
okuyor belki 10 yıl okuyor sonra
memleketine dönüyor İstanbul'dan hiç
çıkmadığı için Türkiye'yi anlatırken
Türkiye ile Aslında yakından uzaktan
alakası olmuyor çünkü Türkiye
İstanbul'dan ibaret değil ve bunlar
memleketlerine dönüyorlar Türkiye'yi
nasıl buldun Nasıl gördün diyorlar ve
anlatıyorlar ve o anlattıkları
Türkiye'nin Türkiye ile aslında bir
alakası yok Ben de bundan dolayı dedim
ki üç ayım var şimdi okullar da kapandı
bir çıkayım Ben
gezeyim Bir de hani Türkiye'nin Anadolu
insanıyla bir oturayım bir kalkayım kim
ne biliyor ne bilmiyor bir öğreneyim
diye öyle bir şeye giriştim yani delilik
desem yeridir Çünkü ben bunu
Barış parasız yaptım Yani beş parasız
harcamadan yaptım
ve bunu bisikletle yaptım Yaptığım
bisiklet de mahalleliyi aldı Yani
mahalleyle öyle bir
muhabbetim oldu
teyzelerime dayılarda Ben genelde
teyzelerine dayılarla çok iyi muhabbet
ederim Çok iyi anlaşırım da ve
böylelikle rotamızı çizdik rotada şu
şekilde İstanbul'dan başlarım İstanbul
işte Sakarya oradan yukarı Bolu
Karadeniz'den Artvin'e kadar o hattı
devam ettim Artvin'den Erzurum Bingöl
orada mı Siirt ve orada Güneydoğu ondan
sonra aşağı indim orada Antep Adana Eee
diye
Akdeniz'e bağladım oradan da tekrar
İstanbul'a geri geldim ve 3 ayım vardı o
yüzden öyle çok İç Anadolu'nun gezme
gibi bir lüksüm yoktu o zaman da
öyle yavaş yavaş öyle dağıttım ve Gezmiş
oldum ve birçok bölgesine de bu şekilde
Gezmiş oldum
Bir de bu gezmelerin hani benim bu gezme
sırasında her noktada çözüm yani çözümü
odaklı böyle püf noktalarımı var hani
neyi nasıl halledeceğimi zamanla o kadar
çözmüşüm ki rahat geziyordum Mesela bir
yere geldik ilk
insanlarla nasıl iletişime geçiyorum
şimdi şöyle bir şey var Türkiye'nin
her yerinde çay var saati önemsizim
her anı her dakikasında çay var o yüzden
benim şunu demem yeterli Selamünaleyküm
Hacılar çayınız var mı
dememle birlikte gel gel Çay var gel
yeğenim gel otur diye muhabbet oradan
başlıyor Ya da ben geçerken bile
meraklarından falan ee çekiyorlar ve o
şekilde sohbet ediyoruz
her yerde öyle giriş yaptığım için de
Türkçe bildiğimi ve Selamünaleyküm
demelere Müslüman
olduğum faslığını kenara aldıktan sonra
samimiyet başlıyor yoksa uzaktan mı ya
zengin bisikletine binmiş nereye gidiyor
bu hani
öyle bir algı oluşabilir selam verdikten
sonra Türkçe konuştuğunu bildikten sonra
sorular bitmiyor ondan sonra böyle bir
soru yağmuruna tutulursa muhabbet oradan
açılır
şimdi gittiğimi her yerde Eee
Hani Türkiye'nin bile zorlandığım
noktalardan biri de o mesela geceleri de
bahsettiğim yani
her yerin farklı bir hikaye var
Anadolu'ya gidiyorsun ayrı bir hikaye
doğuya gidiyorsun ayrı bir çay herkesin
içtiği çay farklı
bu şekilde dil konusunda da mesela ayak
uydurmam gerekiyor gittiğim her bölgede
ve Türkiye biliyorsunuz yani Kültür her
yörenin kültürü çok farklı ve her
yörenin insanın
şivesi konuşma yapısı o kadar farklılık
Yani bu Türk O kim diyor yani
çünkü Çok farklılar şimdiye yapıları
Mesela diyelim ki Karadeniz'den doğuya
Yani bu iki insanın aynı memlekette
olduğunu bil şahit ise
konuşma tarzıları nasıl karşıladıklarını
vesaire
ve biz Türkiye'de Mesela diyelim ki o
zamanlar ben 5 ay 5 yılı İstanbul'daydım
çıkmadım yani bilmiyorum genel olarak
şiveleri falan
gidiyorsun Karadenizli diyorum ki sana
ne ediyorsun
İlk başlarda Hani anlamam doğuya
gidiyorsun zaten apayrı bir şey onları
da işte senin öğrendiğini o Bilmem soru
işaretidir
sen buraya İstanbul'a geliyorsan
soru işareti nerede sağlayacağım ben yok
yani Ege'ye gidiyorsun Onlar apayrı
Onlar zaten
anlaman imkansız seçmen imkansız
oturdun köşede
İstanbul'dan yarar farklı bir büyük bir
şehirden İnşallah okumuş bir adam gelir
de öyle anlaşırım diye umuyorsun
Çünkü onların şivesinden anlamanın zaten
imkanı yok oradaki kişiler de anlamıyor
yani
İlk başları veririm ben kesin bu
sallıyordur Öyle ki konuşuyorlar yoksa
anlaştıklarından değil yani öyle
düşünüyorsun ama öyle değil gerçekten
konuşuyorlarmış
zamanında çözmeye başlayınca diyorsun ki
ya sen oraya Niye yutuyorsun
yani Ee Demir geliyorlar buraya
geliverlar
ne anladım ben bundan yani onu çözene
Kadar dinle dinle dinle teyze yavaş
yavaş yani çok acı konuştuklarını
düşünüyorlar bütün mesele bu
Neyse bu en büyük Yaşadığım
sorumluluklardan biri bu çünkü kültürü
çözdüm Ben artık Türkçe biliyorum diye
hava geçiniyordum falan hani bunları
gittikçe gittikçe diyorum ki ya kardeş
bu nasıl olacak yani gidiyorsun o ayrı
gidiyorsun o ayrı ama meğerse bu
farklılıklar en güzel tarafıymış
zamanla fark ediyorum yani insan ki ben
7 tane İlke gezmişim gibi ya da 7 tane
farklılık kültür tanımışım gibi oldu
Halbuki bir ülke gezerken Türkiye'nin
öyle bir
güzelliği var
gezim sırasında
en güzel şeylerden biri Köyü
istihbaratını diye bir şey var
köye istihbarata ne demek mesela
köyün içerisine girerken bir teyzeyi
rastlıyorsun diyelim kendini özet
geçiyorsun Ben afrikalıyım İstanbul'da
bisikletle geziyorum Türkiye'yi böyle
böyle böyle sıralıyorsun Ondan sonra
devam ediyoruz kahvehaneye gidiyorsun
Orada da sıralıyorsun
Ondan sonra devam ediyorsun o köyde o
gün kalıyorsan bütün köy artık seni
tanıyordu
Çünkü ben geçer geçmez daha iki adım
geçmeden Hatice orada bir kara oğlan
geliyordu
anlatmaya başlıyorlar
ve şöyle oluyorum Yani diyelim ki bu
köye geçtim Bir dahaki köye gidiyorum
Daha beni o köye giriş yapmadan herkes
telefonuna sarılmış böyle bekliyor beni
Çünkü önceki Köyü aramış demiş ki bir
kara oğlan geliyor bisikleti
onları da telefonlarına kaçırmayın diye
ben oradan değilim ki
bayırdan yukarıya gelirken
bir tane insan Telefonu açmış böyle
bekliyor
çok tuhaf oluyor
öyle sanki
[Müzik]
değişik bir
kart oluyor ve gittiğimde herkes hani
ben misafir edeyim ben misafir edeyim
diye yarışıyorlar
Ben de gittiğim her köyde muhtarı
arıyorum
ve muhtarların şöyle hava kolay hava
girme şeyleri var biliyorsunuzdur
Muhtar beni alıyor Sanki ben
İstanbul'dan gelmiyor
Afrika'dan misafirimi geliyormuşum gibi
geçtiği her yerde Afrika'dan bizim
misafirimiz var ona selam veriyor
Bilmiyorum Ona şey çakıyor
çoğu zaman bana şunu diyorlar
sorarlarsa Afrika'dan geliyorsun tamam
mı İstanbul'dan geliyorum de
Sanki ben Türkiye'ye o muhtarı görmeye
geldim ama Muhtarım
pohpohlaman gerekiyor o muhtarı
muhtarımız Evet
Afrika'ya kadar gelmiş olayına katılıyor
Neyse bir keresinde Karadeniz'de
muhtarların böyle eşekle gezmeye eee
şeyleri var falan bezimi
onunla birlikte gidelim yok diyor sen
ben o eşek bilmiş illa beni eşeği
bindirecek eşek de onu tanıyor yani
eşek ve öyle zorla eşeği alıp öyle girip
diriltmeye ve benim köye girişlerinde
her köye girişimde böyle farklı
hikayeler yaşıyorum Bir keresinde yine
Karadeniz'de
köye giriş yapıyorum bir adam beni
durdurdu ama o kadar çok güzel giyinmiş
ki dedi ki sivil askerim evraklarını
çıkar Sana kim gezmeyi şey yapmış ne
derler izin vermiş de buraları
geziyorsun ama nasıl böyle hararetli
konuşuyor
Benim de yetişmem gereken Ne bileyim 50
km yaptıysam 30 km daha yapmam gerekiyor
dedim Ben bununla hırgır işine girmeyin
direkt
evraklarımı vereyim de teslim edeyim de
şey yapayım evraklar almış orada bekle
dedi geliyorum dedi evraklarını bir
bakayım ben de o sırada bir yere girdim
sohbet edeyim falan diye meğerse köyün
delisiymiş
meğerse köyün delisiyim Ben bunu
kahvehaneye geldikten sonra öğreniyorum
bütün evraklarım onda diyorum ki ya
burada bir sivil asker var benim
evraklarımı aldı
nasıl alabilirim Ne yapabilirim diye
tarif ettim Saçlarını böyle mı taradı
şöyle mi yap dedi dediler ve köyün
delisi dediler yani orada Şok Oldum
şimdi gittiğim yerlerde
benim gezimin amacı tarihi yerlerdeydi
daha çok
insanla iletişim Çünkü insanlara işte
Afrika hakkında ne biliyorsun Afrika
böyledir şöyledir işte Öncelikle
Afrika'nın bir ülke olmadığını bilmen
gerekiyor Mesela dayıyı anlatıyorum Dayı
bana diyor ki
memleketin nere diyor yani
negal diyorum
Yav diyor Yok Onu demiyorum senin
memleketin Benim Memleketim Türkiye
diyor senin memleketin nereye Senegal
diyorum
baktım Anlamayacak dedim ki Dayı Afrika
he onu de ya Afrika ülkesini biliyoruz
diyor
ama Ey
Vallah hiç Tamam dedim Evet
sen afrikalısın ama Afrika'yı
Bilmiyorsun bile duydum yani mesela
birliğim yerde mesela
arkadaş ortamı ya da gezdiğim yerlerde
öyle şeyler bekliyor ki Afrika'ya böyle
Fantastik ne bileyim kapının önünde
Aslan besliyorum orada biraz daha
fantastik şeyler anlatıyorlar Sen bir
düz şeyler anlatınca
Neyse dayı anlat da dedi ki Afrika böyle
Afrika şöyle bilmem şöyle dedi ki bu
Afrikalı Bu da biliyor dedi Dedim yok
öyle bir Afrikalı bilmiyorum dedim
Dayı baktı baktı söyleyecek bulamadı
dedi bu Afrikalı ama Afrika'yı bilmiyor
dedi Biz ne bileyim belgeselleri de
izliyoruz hepsi falan diye işte
belgesellerde görülür her Afrika Afrika
olmuyor çıkış amacımda ve gezmeye
amacımda biraz
oydu diyeyim
neyse gittim
yani girdiğim köylerde böyle karşılanmak
Onlara anlatmak onlara işte biraz daha
farklı Afrika imajı Çünkü orada mesela
Bazı yerlerde hazır bildikleri şeyler
var Bazı yerlerde senin orada Nasıl
anlattıysan ya da senin davranışınla
ilgili bir Afrika imajı oluşuyor o
yüzden böyle o konuda bayağı bir dikkat
etmeye çalışıyordum ve öyle
yerlere daha önce de anlattım öyle
yerlere küçük yaşta değil yani Mesela
doğunun bazı yerlerini gidiyorsun Hiç
bir insanın siyah olabileceğine dair bir
Fikri Yok ya Yani bir insan bu kadar
siyahsa kesin boyadı onun kafasındaki
mantık
anlattığım Bazı yerlerde anlattığım bir
teyze var Bingöllü bir teyze
Neyse
girdim sohbet ediyoruz
aldı beni oğlu 40 45 yaşları arasında
bana dedi ki
Annem var yaşlı ama hiç sizin gibi
insanları görmemiş diyor televizyonda
bile görmemiş
yani orada akıllı adam yani düşün bu
adam bu kadın görmediyse Çünkü benim
dayılar falan hani görüp de
şaşırıyorlardı benim orada akıllanmam
gerekiyordu da neyse girdik kadın bir
şeyler örüyordu
anne çaldı dedi ki sana bir sürprizim
var dedi
[Alkış]
Neyse ben de böyle 32 dişimle
şöyle Odaya girdim
Ben girer girmez kadın
diye böyle elindeki bütün örgüleri
Bilmem havaya atmış
Ondan sonra işte koşuşmalar su
getirmeler Zazaca konuşuyorlar zaten
anlamadım ben bir buçuk saattir ter
içinde kaldım yani bisiklet sürerken bu
kadar değer içinde olmuyorum yani acaba
siyahi olduğu için bir ilk böyle katili
olan adam diye tarihe geçecek miyim diye
manşetler geldi ya gözümün önünde böyle
Gazete manşetleri
[Müzik]
öyle yerleri girdim öyle yerlerle oturup
sohbet ettim öyle yerleri keşfettim
insanlarla oturup yani şöyle diyeyim ben
o
birbirimize ne kadar sevgi beslediğimizi
fark ediyorsun orada
Ve bu çok büyük bir
arttı ve gittiğim her bölgede Her
bölgede çok önemli şeyler öğrendim
Mesela benim Türkiye'yle
gezide daha iyi anladım Bu arada
sıkmıyorum umarım benim çok da uzatmamam
gerekiyor
yani Türkiye'de öğrendiğin en önemli şey
deseler ne okuduğum okul ne lise neyini
verse ne bir şey Benim Türkiye'de
öğretmen ve deprem zamanında da gördüm
en önemli şey teşkilatçılık yani
teşkilatçılığı o kadar
güzel o kadar müthiş yapıyorlar ki yani
ikinci bir örneği daha yok diyebilirim
yani Ve benim gezip sırasında gittiğim
her yerde köyde Hatta çocukların
arasında bile
bizde Mesela örnek
bizde Mesela bir Derneği kurmak
gidermeyi kurdum diyebilmen için 40
yaşına 50 yaşına gelmiş olman lazım
Hatta Dernek
gülüp emekli olacağım da benim
oturacağım vakit geçireceğim hani burada
bahçe olduğu gibi biz de dermek anlayışı
o ama burada Dernek ne zaman başlıyor
ortaokul Lise yani bu çok önemli
öğrendiğimiz bir şey ve biz Aslında
Dernek veya teşkilatçılık
şeyini öğrendiğimizde aslında bir araya
gelme şeyini başlayacağımızı Orada fark
ettim
O yüzden arkadaşlara Ne bileyim
yabancılar olsun Ondan sonra buraya
eğitime gelmiş Bütün arkadaşlarımı onu
özellikle tavsiye ederim yani burada
Dernek bir şey gördüğünüzde mesela bu
programda bunun bir örneği Yani bütün
bunlar insanların bir araya gelmesi ve
neredeyse neyin ne olduğunu anlaması
açısından önemli bir şeydir
Son
sözlerimi Ee
bitirirken bir hikaye daha anlatayım
Bingöl'de Yani beni en etkileyen
hikayelerden biri neredeyse yolumu
kesecek kadar Bingöl'de Baran diye bir
çocuk vardı
Baran ben şehre girer girmez yani Baran
Aslında Baran Ahmet de olabilirdi Ve
çoğu yerde de yaşadım benzerlerini ama
bu etkileri beni Baran ben orada Bahçeli
büyüklerle otururken geldi yanıma çiçek
vardı elimde çiçek uzattı bana verdi
Baran da elinde tartı olan bir çocuk ve
annesi hasta babası vefat etmiş Her gün
böyle tartıyla çıkıyor 20 TL 30 TL Neyse
topluyor
annesini götürüyor onlar da öyle
geçmiyor küçük de bir kardeşi var benim
onu verdikten sonra
sohbet ettik biraz meraklı da hani
soruyor bana Afrika'dan mı geliyorsun
nedir ne değildir diye
sohbet etmeye başlayınca dedim ki sen
gel Biz gezmeye başlayalım Çünkü
Bingöl'de gerçekten hani siyahı
görmemişler çok belki televizyonda falan
görmüşlerdi ama birisi yani Özellikle
bisikletini bilip oraya gelmesi belki
Türkiye'de
bir ilktir Neyse girdik başladık pazara
dolaşmaya çalışayım
kalabalık bulduğumuz yerde koyuyoruz
tartı Ben de duruyorum böyle heykel gibi
gelene diyorum ki fotoğraf çekilmek
istiyorsan bir şey bırakacaksın 5
liradır 10
lira çekiniyor fotoğraf bırakırsa
bırakır bırakmazsa da bırakmaz Neyse
öyle yaptık Sonra günün sonunda bir
baktık
işte
ama nasıl Teşekkürler nasıl sevinmeler
Hani onun aklında
Afrika imajı öyle kalması o kalmış oldu
Ee ve bu sadece hani bir hikaye için
bile sadece o yıllara tedavi edeyim Ee
değerli diye düşünüyorum Çünkü o çocuk
Ee o gün götürüldü ama hayatı boyunca
böyle bir anı kalmış onun için benim de
ee kalmış olduğu çünkü bayağı etkiledi
Ee bu yaptığım ya da ne bileyim bu
yapmaya kalkıştım Halbuki yol boyunca
Türkler bana yaptığı
Aynısını ben bir kere Belki geri yapmış
oldum ama öyle bir etki Ee bıraktı ondan
ve çok büyük bir
Yani önemli bir dönüm noktası oldu benim
için de o yüzden güzel bir anı olarak
bende kaldı diyorum ve sözlerimi
bitiriyorum daha çok sıkmadan
[Alkış]